[Music]
a ceasefire between armenia and
azerbaijan is due to come into effect
in around three hours it follows two
weeks of intensive fighting over the
disputed region
of nagorno-karabakh the d the deal was
announced by russian foreign minister
sergey lavrov
after talks in moscow cinema kosher
reports from the city of mingashvir in
azerbaijan
it's the first direct contact known to
have taken place between armenia and
azerbaijan
since the new fighting broke out on
september 27th
a ceasefire has been declared from 12
o'clock on october 10th for humanitarian
purposes
to exchange prisoners and the bodies of
the dead it'll be done
under the guidance of the international
red cross
the moscow talks came after the
azerbaijan foreign minister attended
talks in geneva
with the french u.s and russian envoys
on thursday
mi verne principle we are committed to a
peaceful settlement of the karabakh
conflict and are ready to resume the
peace process in accordance with the
recent statements of the presidents and
foreign ministers
of the osce mints group but just as the
talks in moscow began
the azerbaijan president ilham alive
said there could be no peace
if armenia continued to insist that
nagorno-karabakh
was part of its territory
everyone should know this including
those in charge of armenia today
i tell them again that if they commit
fraud after the moscow talks
they will regret it we will take back
our lands
peacefully or through war unequivocally
we want to organise it peacefully we
give armenia
one last chance for the last two days
efforts to stop the fighting between
armenian azerbaijan have been held
while the battles in and around
nagorno-karabaw continue to rage
it still remains to be seen whether this
latest international
effort to achieve a ceasefire will be
successful
the fighting is the worst since the
1991-94 war
that killed an estimated 30 000 people
and ended with a ceasefire that has been
repeatedly violated
azerbaijan says that 31 azeri's
civilians had been killed and 168
wounded since september 27.
it has not disclosed information about
military casualties
authorities in nagorno-karabakh say 376
of its military personnel and 22
civilians have been killed
during the dame period sinam kusolo
al-jazeera
has more on the ceasefire announcement
from moscow
it's a kind of a humanitarian ceasefire
with the purpose
of the exchange of prisoners and other
people that are detained by both sides
as well as for handing over the bodies
of the people that have been killed
since the
27th of september when this
conflict started this is to be happening
under the observation of a red cross
he also said that the parties agreed to
start substantial negotiations
and he also said that the parties agreed
that the format of this negotiation is
not going to change
which i think means that it will stay
within
the osce minsk group co-chaired by
russia france and united states a group
that has been established
in the 90s to end the original uh
conflict that has been frozen
since sedan so what is to follow what is
for us to see
is whether this ceasefire is indeed
going to happen
as agreed if it is really going to
come down to the exchange of prisoners
and if the parties
are really willing to start negotiating
and
to really return to the negotiating
table to solve this
decades-long conflict in
nagorno-karabakh